Well,
welcome.
Thank you very much for coming today.
My name is Charles Hilton.
I am a social entrepreneur,
meaning that I use this business principles and social market issues,
market issues to deal with social issues.
I had represent four different organizations here.
Uh,
the one that you might know the best is the rice man here.
Second Harvest Japan.
And so today I'm gonna talk to you about how to motivate,
how we use a concept here called starting with why and basically the three parts
of this presentation right now and tell you a little bit about,
more about myself and what we do at second harvest.
I'm going to show you the whole video from Simon Sinek.
Has Anybody seen his video?
You have?
Okay,
good.
Well hope you're not bored to see it again.
And then I'm going to show you how we apply it at our organization and because
we found that this be very important.
So let's just get started.
I want to show you a quick video of Lou about what we do.
I am
[inaudible]
Stop,
stop.
So I love this picture here because it illustrates clearly what we do.
All that food and all the food that you saw in that video,
there would have been food and thrown away.
Okay.
It's a cost to the donor to throw it away and no company or personal interest.
He wants to throw away food but they don't know where to get it to.
We come in,
this is my staff,
my former staff,
pick it up and get out to people for them and now has value.
But in that process of picking it up,
what used to be a problem,
a cost to that donor company is now a value.
They can say they're doing CSR.
They could say that they're engaging the community and their staff feel better
about the company,
feel better about their product,
knowing that it goes right back into the community to be used that day.
On the recipient side of it,
obviously they can use the food and nourish himself with food is also a tool for
communication,
particularly single mother households where quite often the mothers are buying
separate vendors to feed the children now with food.
They can,
they can cook together as a way to communicate.
So this is really kind of encapsulates what we're trying to do,
make food available to anybody in need,
but to kind of understand our philosophy and where it comes from and who we are
today.
Need to go back 20 years ago.
So I've been in now in Japan for over 26 years and lived in a poor section of
Tokyo,
made a self help center there.
But by the end of 1996 I had questions about the viability of that.
And so I chose to go live along the submitter river and only intended to be
there for three months.
It's good to see you again.
And I ended up staying there 15 months and it completely changed my worldview.
It's one thing to think about poverty,
one thing about hunger in the comfort of one's own home or in academia,
it's quite different than when you have people living to the left and right.
He viewed no more than two or three meters away.
That struggle with that issue you each and every day and asking yourself,
what should I do?
What can I do?
What is my responsibility here?
And so while I knew these people many years before I went to go live down there,
it was quite new experience to come down here as we say,
live in the Gemba to live side by side together and it completely changed my
mind.
Okay.
One day I was looking over the river just like this,
contemplated thinking about the men and think about how people thought about the
men and and some people think that their cow ISO,
some people think that they're there.
Joshua,
why are they down there?
And I thought about my own life here in Japan up to that point and some people
would welcome me.
People had not welcomed me.
I've been discriminated against.
I thought about a child in Calcutta street,
child in Calcutta was hungry and thought about their situation,
how I felt when I saw that child in Calcutta and I thought about other social
issues in the world.
Climate Change,
land mines in Afghanistan,
Hey,
number one of these things and it came back to this phrase back over and over
again.
You may be familiar with this phrase.
If you're not a part of the solution,
you're part of the problem.
Over and over in my head,
I'm thinking about this as I'm looking at these men.
I thought about the men.
They didn't feel that way.
They didn't feel anybody else's responsible for them.
I thought about the discrimination I face and I didn't want anybody to fight my
own battles,
not thought about that child and Calcutta and I said,
you know,
I didn't make that child poor or knew him in the social issues
and I had experienced it radically changed my whole worldview and an insight
that I had was quite often westerners sense of guilt about the world's problems
is deeply rooted in an exaggerated sense of responsibility
that people feel over sense of responsibility for the world's problems and I
shifted from feeling responsible for the world's problems to choosing to
respond.
And I'll give you one just quick story here to clear,
clarify how that plays out in my life.
Several years later,
I was in Seattle with my brother who is five years younger,
but probably two times bigger than I am.
He's fairly muscular and I'm panhandler a guy begging for money,
had the courage to come out to both of us and say,
can you spare $5 typical response,
typical thing,
right and without thinking,
without even pausing,
I turned in with no sarcasm of my boys.
I said,
I'll pass on that opportunity.
My brother,
he walked away,
he looked at me like this and my brother looked at me like,
what the heck you're passing it,
the opportunity.
I said,
well,
he gave me an opportunity to do something good and I,
I just chose not to do that.
Now,
if I had not had that opportunity,
that experience along the river,
I am most likely response would have been,
well,
if I give him the money,
he's going to use it for drinking or he doesn't look like he needs it or some
reason why I didn't need to get them food,
but what I was really kind of responding to there was I'm not responsible for
him.
Whereas now my worldview is I choose to respond to what we do.
And we'll get into that in a minute here.
When we talk about second harvest,
what our core why is
that perspective that I had in that experience and we talked about and the other
day and he talks about ICU is not unique.
Meaning that all of us have these opportunities each and every day to step back
and reflect on our life.
What is day to day experiences mean to how do they reflect our,
our values,
our worldview.
You don't need to live along Sumida river to have an insight like that.
And I want to share one more to you then.
I stumbled across in 2013 I was teaching at Sofia University in Geo management
and I stumbled across this video.
I'm a leader,
so this really spoke directly to me.
I said,
well,
let me look at it.
And I said,
Oh my God,
this guy has been,
he's saying we are doing what he says we're doing,
but people would,
companies do.
And since that time we've used it to refocus who we are,
how we approach things.
So we saw this last year's campaign almost played out just exactly.
If you look at these two different candidates as your three different
candidates,
we clearly knew what Clinton wanted.
She wanted the presidency.
She had a campaign to do that.
Talk badly about Trump.
How bad,
how crazy he is.
Okay.
Trump and Sanders.
Then inside,
clearly we knew what their why was.
You can debate what that exactly was,
but there's no doubt among their supporters.
You knew exactly what their why was and how they connected with them was
different ways.
Sanders,
very grounds,
grassroots,
Trump,
big rallies and the what?
The idea of becoming president,
it was almost an afterthought for both of them.
You can look at online articles and people consistently say,
we don't know why Clinton ran.
We know she wanted to be the president,
but what was your why?
But these two people,
there's clearly,
and just as he was talking about the airplane and vendors,
the Wright brothers and Samuel Pierpont Langley,
whereas Clinton today,
if she was truly about her wife changed in the country,
it wouldn't matter.
She was a politician or not
in our sense and who we are as an organization,
our core,
why
we don't define what we do is helping people.
Okay.
Set One more time.
We do not define what we do is helping people.
We just love food banking.
We just love giving away food.
That me pause for a second and ask you how many people were surprised by that
statement?
Yeah.
Coming from a nonprofit,
how many would you raise your hand if you like?
Yeah,
you're surprised,
right?
Right.
But how many of you,
when I,
you heard me say we just love food banking.
You felt some energy,
you felt oh yeah.
Because almost every single time when I have one on one discussion with people
and I say this,
I could see that people's face change and it's,
it's not because they agree with me about giving away food.
We'll talk about that in a second,
but they can clearly identify and connect with my core why.
You could see the energy in my face that came from that 20 years ago.
Living along the river of choosing not to responsible but to responding.
In my one of my responses to give away food.
How do we do that?
Trust in inequality,
trusting inequality.
70% of Japanese distrust nonprofits,
70% we're only less than 30% say that they would trust a nonprofit.
Here in Japan,
we interface everyday with the food industry,
which is probably the strictest standards in the world for food and the least
risk adverse or the most risk is risk adverse.
I think I always get that mistaken.
2014 United States,
there were 3,400 people died from food poisoning or foodborne illnesses.
The United States,
320 million people.
That's not a lot of people.
Okay.
Within the last five weeks over that number of people have died from gunshot
wounds.
The United States,
so we're not talking about a lot of people,
but that same year,
2014 in Japan,
just three people,
just three people died from food borne illnesses.
Population of 120 million consuming nearly 89 million tons of food.
We're importing and using it.
That is not a lot to get to that level.
You have to have NASA like standards free food.
You do not trust anybody.
We say in Japan at the product is imperfect,
Pristina presentable.
It doesn't get purchased.
That's the environment we were operating it,
so we need to create trust and here's our,
here's the results.
10 years ago we only had 15 companies.
Now we have over 1300 here's the interesting thing.
We don't do any solicitation.
We don't go around company,
a company asking for food.
All 1300 of those companies approached us and sat down with us and offered us an
agreement and all 1300 companies.
We have what we call it,
an equal relationship with them.
Why is it so important for us?
It's not a matter of pride.
It's a matter of our approach.
If we go around company company and say,
I chammas unintentionally,
it puts the company above here.
It puts us down here so that when we pass out our food,
the people are down here and we're up here.
Okay?
We see food as a tool.
Companies have pumps and patches.
People over here have bikes with flat tires.
If we could make that lateral transfer.
That's all we want to be.
That's all we want to do.
That equality part is important.
What I will tell a company,
it sits down in front of me.
I'll say,
we are not interested in your food.
We want a trusting relationship with you and we will match your pace for pace to
achieve that and then I'll go on to give two examples and each they foods in
2005 sign an agreement with us after just three short weeks but needs you.
They foods is traditionally very,
very company,
a different company,
which we never name but it's an actual fact.
Took us five years,
five years.
See,
I don't want the food for them.
What I want is then it gets so excited about what we do that till two or three
other people and here it is right here.
The what we do,
right?
You could find that on our homepage or an report.
Obviously we provide food to people in a lot of different ways.
This is the end result of what we do,
right?
But when we talk about and think about us,
we go from how,
why,
how,
what in our discussions,
we use this this week
to work through a problem that we've had for many,
many years and the problem and focus around the issue of food loss and food
waste,
big topic in the,
in the media.
You know,
if people talk about it all the time,
oh,
there's one third of food is thrown away.
You know,
a 25% of food is thrown away.
There's people hungry and stuff like this.
Okay?
Yeah.
But we all being in the field and being experts in this area knew that a lot of
what was being said was uninformed,
uneducated,
and unsupported.
And so we would always criticize these,
these different activities,
the zero and kitchen,
having to go window food laws,
all of these.
And so my staff member candidates who says,
what are we gonna do?
We can't run away from this issue.
People are always talking about it.
You know,
we've gotta be part of the conversation even if no,
we don't believe in,
in the movement.
Okay?
In other words,
there are 155 definitions for food loss.
Even countries that have a single definition,
there's no way to measure how much food losses,
right?
If you can't measure it,
you can't manage it.
Correct.
If the United States,
my country,
the government reports anywhere from 33 million to 66 million,
depending on what definition they use.
Okay,
so how are we going to square this?
Well,
we had good discussion and what we realize is that we were focusing on from the
what side,
right?
And so we came back said,
what is our why?
What is our core?
Why would just love to give away food?
Right?
And so my staff and I each shared a story of that we own had,
he went to India at one time and so a child was begging for food and instead of
just giving the child food or money,
he said,
well come and not,
I'll feed you.
And he ended up feeding 10 of his family members at a restaurant.
No,
I shared in my mind as a child not having enough food,
not having lunches.
And what that meant to me,
and now have an opportunity to give away food,
right?
And then we thought about,
well,
wait a minute,
these people over here,
you know,
what's,
what's going on there at their core,
they're why.
Well,
food is life,
right?
Our fondest,
deepest memories are usually connected to food,
whether it be a wedding holidays,
when we feel bad and good,
good food,
right?
Maybe our mothers might've made us food that comfort us,
but food is such an integral part of us and the t that thrown away,
right?
I love Japanese phrase of [inaudible],
but we said,
hey,
you know what?
How about we,
we,
we focus on it here and then we talk about how we can use that food as life.
This is the intersectionality and avoid all this.
Okay?
And suddenly we went from being confrontational each time about their what to
refocusing on what is important to us and how can we talk about food loss and
food waste in a way that reflects our values in a way that doesn't alienate
other people.
The last one,
and it's important with this discussion,
is that I can go down and tell you all the things that are wrong with here,
with numbers and facts and figures.
That's all that is,
is facts and figures,
but I tell you a story about myself,
right?
I'm not having enough,
you know,
food for breakfast or not being able to,
have lunch or my,
my call,
they can tell you about him sharing dinner.
That's a memory.
That's an experience that you can remember,
all right?
And that can motivate us that then how does it,
how can we share more food?
Our vision is by 2020 that we want to make food available to 100,000 people,
right?
Currently there are about 2.2 million people that lack food security.
The vast majority of these people are elderly.
The national population for homeless is only around 6,200 nationally.
In Tokyo it's less than 2000 okay.
The vast majority of people that are in need are not living on the streets.
They're living in houses and apartments to get access to food.
This week in New York City,
they're 1100 different locations to pick up food.
Even nearby Hong Kong,
he has 200 has 160 Tokyo,
maybe six.
And I'm not referring to church groups or other faith based groups that provide
only Gideon the park.
I'm talking where you can pick up a basket of food to feed your family for three
or four days.
Okay.
So we think of it like climbing a mountain some ways and our first step up that
mountain by 2020 is the each 100,000 our big goal,
right?
The big one.
You know that we hope to get there some days that everybody has enough food and
we want to think of it like a public service,
a public asset.
I live way out in the countryside.
It takes me about almost hours to get home every day.
I almost never use the public library,
you know?
But if I felt the public library wasn't there,
I would feel a public asset was gone as valuable to me.
I'm happy to pay taxes to make sure that library open,
because it's not just a place for people to read books,
but it's a place for people to get knowledge of people,
to experience a different world,
a place for people to share information.
It's valuable to us and that's how we want to see what of Satan ideas is that
even if you don't use it today,
somebody in the community might navel to use it.
And even if you may never experienced food insecurity,
you know what it's like to have everybody at the table.
And if I were to ask you this,
take a step just for a second,
and imagine that every single child in Tokyo by 2020 could go to school on a
full stomach.
How would that feel?
Yeah.
For me personally,
it makes me feel good.
Even though I don't know all of those children.
We have plenty of food.
So this is where your opportunity to respond,
you know,
to partner with us.
Use Your talents to help us to get food.
All right?
There's different ways you can interact with us to make that happen.
I know some of you are coming out tomorrow.
That's great.
And then also financially,
if you've ever donated to us financially,
you may want to know what impact does that have for every thousand yen.
You deliberate,
you donate to us.
We can deliver 40 meals.
We arrive at that number by taking our total costs overhead,
everything and dividing by the number of meals that we were able to deliver last
year.
Okay,
Libby,
last two quotes here.
I love these um,
one by Martin Luther King,
but Pete plays on Hillel,
the elder,
uh,
if not us then who,
if not now,
then when we reflect that in that internally that we don't want to assign this
work to other people,
wait for other people to take action,
but we want to do something and we want to do whatever we can do today and not
wait till we retire or wait till something changes in our life.
Even a small action today could have a big impact.
The second one doe speaks more deeply to us as an organization.
How we see the world.
It comes from Robert Kennedy there.
Those,
look at the things where they are and ask why I do my things that never were,
and ask why not?
Instead of focusing on why is there all this food waste,
why isn't the government do something more?
Why we want to say,
what would it look like if you and I partnered?
What would it look like if you and I put our heads together?
What would that banquet table look like if we took some action today to make
something happen,
to focus on what the possibilities are?
There's a lot more information on our website here.
It's bilingual and you can download some information.
Thank you very much for your time today.
Thank you.
[inaudible].